[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
another video on the repose and
variation of the Queen's Gambit and this
time we need to examine an early Queen
check on a form so let's start we um
start with the usual moves to lead to
the recursion and some in this chapter
we look at Queen a for check this idea
is frequently seen on many moves like
here so early as possible on move five
but we have already seen this idea with
the white having traded on d5 first or
having played Bishop g5 first and then
Queen a form there are a number of trans
positions for example I mean we have to
play ninety six we can put that on the
board for example after ninety six white
may still play C takes d5 or Bishop g5
and then we will have a quick
transposition to earlier chapters um
let's have a quick look at this just to
make sure that we are on the same page
after this we get to enter in your
chapter where white captures first and
then gives the check this is an
important line I think it happens quite
frequently um
wide also may play Bishop g5 after which
we play age six and then we also
transpose this time to the very first
chapter in the course which deals with
Bishop g5 on the fifth move so here why
it can take we take with the Queen and
we have transposed the same happens
after Bishop age four after we take of
course and this is a line known to be
very okay for us as we know from the
first chapter and then Bishop h4 s not a
good reply to the early Bishop g5
so these transpositions don't want to
worry us at all white most of the time
now play
the move III this makes a lot of sense
as the capture on c4 is something that
White has to think about and III covers
the pawn um we should talk a little bit
about general strategy here for black
how do we handle this position um with
the knight on c6 it's pretty clear that
we have a hard time to get c5 in this
would be a natural way to attack the
white center but this is difficult now
it's still not impossible in some lines
we will see that we will move the knight
and c5 still happens but it's not
something that is easily accomplished
um and what we will do instead is to
focus on a different way of developing
our game and that is with the move e5 we
would like to play this to open up the
bishop and the main way to accomplish
this in this line is to later withdraw
the Bishop to d6 and play e5 the issue
with Bishop d6 can be that white pushes
c5 this is very annoying so we will
often or basically all of the time if we
go 45 take on c4 first so our idea would
be to capture on c4 play Bishop d6 then
play e5 we would seem that this is the
standard way of handling this line now
me3 is as mentioned the main move but
white can try some other moves that we
should check um the move Bishop d2 is
sometimes seen breaking the pin and
still having maybe e3 in mind later
there is a drawback of this move and you
can probably already I guess what the
drawback is it is that we can take on c4
this is a good moment to do it because
white does not easily recover this pawn
it has to go through some length to
actually manage III makes a lot of sense
to get this idea in we play Bishop d7
and this is something that is very
commonly seen against the
in only four we are now threatening the
discovered attack night 64 so there is
just no alternative for white then to
withdraw the Queen he has to move the
Queen again so this Queen check is kind
of a double-edged sword for white it
gains a little bit of let's say
strategic it has a strategic again as
the knight on c6 can be a tricky it can
be a tricky pose for the night but the
Queen it was a lot of charm now what are
we doing here
black IAM has a thing a very good way of
handling this position and this is to
play Knight to a5 simply trying to make
use of the night this is often what you
have to do if you have a piece that is
not perfectly placed
think about what upside this currently
not ideal post has and here Knight a5 is
indeed a good idea we cover this pawn
and ask white about his intentions how
to recover it 95 is a very obvious means
now and will probably be played if
something slow happens like we should be
too we will carry out the c5 push
something that I talked about earlier
it's still not completely off the map
aligned like this it looks very
comfortable the night is still covering
the pawn and very likely in some
sequence will be traded after white has
taken on c4 here we have no problem at
all we have an easy easy way to this was
a free preview of our entire one d4
course based on the nimzo-indian and
rogozin available on chess about calm
thanks for watching and see you soon
[Music]